ah here we go mr. Willie goes ok let's
see how he how it works out with my
playing a quicker playing quicker
approach against my my nemesis here two
wins 14 losses and a couple of drawers
isn't that a great statistic amazing
yeah I'm just playing move move move
move move yeah not taking long here we
know how it works against him so
something like this Queen a 7 SB 5 i'm
actually add on the clock and I can
absolutely assure you that I will play
on time any position against a move it
will come to that so I can take this one
so what about b5 here in this position
is that an idea b5 takes c6 looks
dangerous we will probably move back
takes him I'm going to take this I know
it is super boring but I have tried to
play something crazy against him it
didn't work we always get the boring end
games in 20 seconds ahead and trying to
try to keep it like that if possible
yeah I don't know but ok I think I want
to prevent 94 I interesting Bishop a 5
as an idea if three looks kind of bad it
looks kind of bad that i have three move
so probably not ok let's go f 3 10
seconds still 10 seconds ahead here
don't really think there's much going on
maybe I'm wrong so was there something
that I can do here and probably not huh
check and give some useless checks still
can go eat five maybe maybeee five
something for him is that something that
I can do when I can go to the night to G
to play for H for such an idea probably
not oh that's just shuffle I'm still
ahead of time check ok
it's really absolutely dead so actually
going for a drone dry yeah I it's just
totally boring him but it's what you get
against him every game don't do it I
mean I was at least quick about it um JR
not much to analyze he just does it like
that all the time but usually I'm like
down 30 seconds and then he wins on time
now we're just played instantly I mean
you never really did something invented
or so very rarely just just traded
everything down to this this is complete
draw and really I think it is just a
draw yeah not much to look at it it's
always like that against him I had tried
the Kings gambit and stuff and it didn't
work out okay well thanks for watching